[Musik]
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt.
Heute gibt es Pizza, und zwar eine Pizza Hut-Pizza.
AARON: Eine Pizza Hut-Pizza? [Sally stimmt zu]
[Singt] Pizza hat, wer Pizza…
Okay, ja?
SALLY: Ich habe die Speisekarte gerade angeschaut
und habe eine Chicken Supreme entdeckt – die machen wir heute.
Das geht, oder - Fleisch?
AARON: Fleisch ist immer gut, aber ich habe noch nie etwas zubereitet.
Ich kann wirklich gar nichts!
SALLY: Kannst du nicht einmal Pizza?
AUS DEM HINTERGRUND: Pfuii!
AARON: Aber das kennst du ja von Murat.
Deswegen musst du mich da durchbringen.
SALLY: Hast du auch noch nie eine Pizza gebacken?
AARON: Nur Fertigteig, Salami drauf und ganz viel Käse.
SALLY: [Atmet tief durch]
Dann wird dieses heutige Video ein 1x1 des Pizzabackens.
AARON: Jaa!
SALLY: Los geht’s mit…?
AARON: Teig. Teig ist die Grundlage von allem.
Teig ist das Fundament und Backen und Kochen ist ein Handwerk.
SALLY: Ja, genau! Für den Teig braucht man nicht viele Zutaten.
Wenn du keine frische Hefe hast, kannst du auch Trockenhefe nehmen.
AARON: Während Corona war Hefe Mangelware, aber voll günstig
- 0,35 € oder so.
SALLY: Oder 0,09 € sogar nur.
AARON: 9? [Sally bejaht] Unglaublich!
SALLY: Ich habe damals ein Video gedreht, wie man Hefe selbst macht
- aus Datteln und Obst.
Dann haben alle damals, vor 7 Jahren, gesagt:
Warum denn Hefe selbst machen? Ist doch voll günstig!
Zu Corona-Zeiten war es das meistgeklickte Video.
AARON: Wirklich?
SALLY: Ja. Hefe selber machen. Haben viele gemacht.
Jedenfalls sind das die Zutaten für den Hefeteig.
AARON: Ich frag nicht… Ich sag nicht…
SALLY: Sag es ruhig.
AARON: Ich dachte, Hefe ist ein Fertigprodukt.
Das wächst einfach irgendwo und dann…
SALLY: Nein. Es sind ja Pilze, die praktisch so gezüchtet werden.
AARON: Ich sag einfach nichts. Sonst wirke ich noch dümmer.
SALLY: Nein! Es lebt ja. Das ist so.
Eigentlich ist es ekelig, finde ich.
Eigentlich ist eine Fermentation schon ekelig.
Egal, es schmeckt gut! [Aaron stimmt zu]
Also ihr braucht 10 g Hefe oder 20 g Trockenhefe, 2 EL Zucker,
450 g Wasser, 900 g Mehl, 2 TL Salz und etwas Olivenöl.
AARON: So. Wo ist die Unterlage? Brauchen wir nicht unsere Unterlage?
SALLY: Nein. Komm, das machen wir jetzt mit der Küchenmaschine.
AARON: Ach so.
SALLY: Das ist einfacher.
Du kannst einfach Zucker, Hefe und Wasser hineingeben.
AARON: Was zuerst?
SALLY: Egal. Zucker ist so ein bisschen die Nahrung.
AARON: Hefe… und das war’s auch schon.
So macht doch Kochen/Backen Spaß.
[Beide lachen]
Ich kann das!
Mir hat mal jemand beigebracht:
Du musst dich auf die Sachen fokussieren, die du kannst,
anstatt auf alles, was du nicht kannst.
SALLY: Ja! Jetzt holen wir kurz den Schneebesen heraus.
Dann kann man das nämlich kurz verrühren.
Oh, sieh an!
AARON: Alles vollgesaut. Nein, doch nicht.
SALLY: Dann darfst du das verrühren.
AARON: Mache ich das nicht hieran?
SALLY: Nein, wir machen das ganz kurz per Hand.
Sonst müssten wir das Rührelement tauschen.
AARON: Das kenne ich von Breaking Bad. [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Okay. Siehst du, Kochen kann er doch gut.
Dann das Mehl hinein.
AARON: Warum haben wir das nicht gleich zusammen reingemacht?
SALLY: Weil die Hefe erst einmal im Wasser mit dem Zucker aufgelöst wird.
Dann hat sie schon einmal eine Nahrung und du weißt dann auch,
dass sie sich gut auflöst.
AARON: Okay.
SALLY: Dann Salz dazu.
AARON: Das bisschen?
SALLY: Ja, 2 TL. Wolltest du gerade… ?
AARON: Ja, wollte ich machen, aber dachte: Nein!
SALLY: Dann kannst du auch schon Öl reinkippen.
AARON: Das ist dein Öl, oder? [Sally bejaht]
Wie viel?
SALLY: Hast du auch, oder? 6 EL!
AARON: Ich habe kein Gefühl, was 6 EL sind.
SALLY: Ich sage Stopp!
[Musik]
AARON: Ich kippe immer noch Öl rein.
[Küchenmaschine]
SALLY: Da kommt ja wenig heraus.
AARON: So? [Sally bejaht] Das ist jetzt schon voll viel, oder?
SALLY: Nein, das reicht. Der Teig knetet jetzt 10 Minuten.
Das könnt ihr entweder mit der Hand oder mit der Küchenmaschine machen.
AARON: Ich empfehle euch die Küchenmaschine.
SALLY: In der Zwischenzeit – guck! –
kann ich mit Siamak Produktabnahme machen.
AARON: Sind das Koch- oder Schmierpinsel?
SALLY: Kochpinsel.
SIAMAK: Ja. Für Fondant usw.
SALLY: Oh cool!
Also, hier ist der Hefeteig.
AARON: Uii!
SALLY: Ist gut, oder?
AARON: Das ist…
SALLY: Guck mal! Fühl mal!
AARON: Schön warm auch.
SALLY: Ich habe ihn warmgemacht.
AARON: Die Maschine? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: 34°C. Dann geht er gleich schneller.
Schön, gell? Jetzt schön die Oberfläche mit Öl einstreichen,
damit sie nicht austrocknet.
Mach mal so eine schöne Kugel!
AARON: Wie? So?
SALLY: So eine Kugelform.
AARON: Ein Kreis? Ein Ball? [Sally stimmt zu] Okay.
SALLY: So ein bisschen von außen nach innen,
dass die Oberfläche glatt wird.
AARON: Ich weiß gar nicht, was… [Sally lacht]
Ich finde es leicht erotisch, aber sonst…
[Sally lacht]
[Erotische Jazzmusik]
SALLY: So!
AARON: Ach so. Aah! Okay. Aah!
Also so ein Kissen formen.
SALLY: Schön, oder?
AARON: Jetzt raffe ich es!
SALLY: Schön.
AARON: Okay. Hop, hop, hop.
Das riecht ja alles immer so gut.
Und jetzt? Oh, die geht kaputt!
SALLY: Jetzt war es zu lang. [Lacht]
AARON: Wirklich? [Sally bejaht] Was soll ich denn jetzt machen?
SALLY: Noch einmal von vorn?
AARON: Wirklich? [Sally bejaht] Nein! Och menno!
Erst geht der Teig kaputt und dann kommt Murat rein.
JACQUES COUSTEAU: 3 Tage später…
SALLY: Sehr schön. Der kommt jetzt hier rein.
AARON: Schon wieder?
SALLY: Ja, der muss jetzt aufgehen.
AARON: Der sieht voll schön aus! [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Das bitte NICHT nachmachen! Der will mit Liebe behandelt werden.
AARON: Ach so. Tschuldigung!
SALLY: Nicht so ein Klapser.
So, guck mal.
AARON: Voll schön.
SALLY: Während er aufgeht, können wir nämlich die Tomatensauce zubereiten.
Da die Tomatensauce nicht so lange dauert, würde ich sagen,
überbrücken wir mit unserer Lieblingsdisziplin…
Karaoke!
AARON: Toll! Ich hasse singen.
[Sarah und Sally singen, Aaron versucht es]
♪ I just can’t stop, I just can’t stop. ♪
♪ I just can’t stop. No, no! ♪
♪ Ich möchte noch gerne noch schauen, ♪
♪ aber der Wagen rollt, der rollt… ♪
[Alle lachen]
AARON: Weiter komme ich auch nicht mehr.
SALLY: Wahnsinn!
SARAH: Das war jetzt ein richtiger Rausschmiss.
AARON: Das ist der Best Song. Den hatte ich immer im Musikunterricht.
So, und jetzt?
SALLY: Schön!
AARON: Ah, ich hasse übrigens Singen.
SALLY: Jetzt gibt es eine Tomatensauce.
Wir nehmen 1 Zwiebel, 1 Knoblauchzehe, Olivenöl, Tomatenmark,
Tomaten aus der Dose und die Gewürze Salz, Pfeffer und Oregano.
Gut, dann lass uns einmal starten.
Schälen und schneiden.
Bei der Zwiebel darfst du immer hier oben die Wurzel immer dranlassen,
weil sie die Zwiebel zusammenhält.
Aber hier oben, da, wo eigentlich die Frühlingszwiebel usw. dranhängt,
kannst du es wegschneiden. Dann kannst du sie besser schälen.
AARON: Und jetzt? Ah, hier ist noch ein bisschen was.
SALLY: Da ist noch ein bisschen. Dann halbieren.
AARON: Wann fängt man denn an zu weinen?
SALLY: Du kannst auch die Zunge rausstrecken.
AARON: Dann?
SALLY: Dann weint man anscheinend nicht.
[Grillengeräusche]
Oder Wasser in den Mund.
Ja genau, so halten.
Aber warte mal – Arbeitssicherheit!
Leg sie einmal so auf.
Ich meinte die Zwiebel, aber egal.
Jetzt so hinlegen und hier so zack, zack, zack, zack einschneiden
und nicht durchschneiden, weil die Wurzel alles zusammenhält.
Nicht so gerade rein.
Bis runter.
AARON: Aber du hast gesagt, nicht durch, nur ein.
SALLY: Soll ich es dir einmal zeigen?
AARON: Bitte.
SALLY: Also…
AARON: Du hast doch gesagt, nicht durch!
SALLY: Ja, nicht hier hinten durch.
AARON: Ach so. Das war jetzt schlecht erklärt.
SALLY: Ja, das war echt schlecht erklärt.
Dann Tunnelgriff, dass man sich nicht schneidet.
AARON: Hast du dich schon mal geschnitten?
SALLY: Ja, oft. Ich habe viele Wunden.
AARON: Stimmt. Krass. [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Sieht man nur nicht.
Dann Krallengriff.
AARON: Messer, Schere sticht, ist für kleine Sally nicht.
SALLY: Und Backofen und Grill.
AARON: Oh ja!
SALLY: Ich verbrenne mich überall.
Du kannst diese schneiden und ich brate sie schon einmal an.
Ich muss zu deiner Verteidigung sagen:
Das Messer muss geschärft werden. Es ist nicht mehr scharf.
AARON: Tunnelgriff!
SALLY: Ja. Und dann so drehen und dann…
AARON: Jetzt hier abschneiden? [Sally bejaht]
Guck mal, das wusste ich auch nicht, wie das geht!
Jetzt? Kommt das auch rein?
SALLY: Genau. Die Knoblauchzehe kannst du auch ein bisschen feinhacken.
Also das mit den Zwiebeln und dem Anbraten muss man nicht machen,
aber ich finde, es schmeckt schon besser, wenn man die Sauce kocht.
AARON: Jetzt merke ich es in den Augen.
So, was mache ich jetzt?
SALLY: Die kannst du auch halbieren und kleinhacken.
Sieht aber gut aus!
AARON: Gibt’s da nicht auch so ein Ding, was es kleinschneidet?
SALLY: Ja, schon. Also eigentlich kann man aller in der Maschine machen.
Aber ich habe ja dich. Du bist auch eine Maschine!
Dann geben wir alle Zutaten hinein
und kochen die Sauce 10 Minuten lang.
AARON: Jetzt alles rein? [Sally bejaht]
Einfach so? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Tomatenmark.
AARON: Schüssel noch auslöffeln?
SALLY: Ja. Voll vorbildlich.
AARON: Das kann ich kippen? [Sally bejaht]
Ja klar!
[Musik]
Wir machen eine fleischige Pizza. Du wolltest etwas mit Fleisch.
Hier haben wir schon die Tomatensauce.
Dann haben wir hier noch rote Zwiebeln,
Sucuk (Knoblauchwurst), Paprika und Hähnchen.
Das Hähnchen können wir noch marinieren.
Und zwar kannst du da ein bisschen Öl reingeben, Paprikapulver…
AARON: Wie viel ist „ein bisschen“?
SALLY: So ein bisschen noch… 1-2 EL.
Hier haben wir noch…
AARON: Balsamico?
SALLY: Balsamico-Creme.
Dann Pfeffer. Also ihr könnt es ja würzen, wie ihr wollt.
Ich hatte hier auch schon Öl vorbereitet. Habe ich vergessen.
AARON: Und jetzt? Umrühren?
SALLY: Ja. Oder du nimmst dir einen Handschuh und kannst einkneten,
aber jetzt hast du nasse Hände.
AARON: Ist ja nicht schlimm, oder?
SALLY: Mit Handschuhe? Ja…
AARON: Ich rühre einfach um, oder?
SALLY: Genau.
AARON: Wo ist die Ablage, dass ich mein…
SALLY: Das können wir wegtun.
Okay, aus dem Teig machen jetzt 4 große Pizzen.
[Musik]
Jetzt kannst du das zur Seite stellen
und dann können wir den Pizzateig zubereiten.
AARON: Ziehe ich den Handschuh aus? Ja? [Sally bejaht]
SALLY: Das sind die Pizzableche.
AARON: Die können auch so rein?
SALLY: Ja. Dann ein bisschen verteilen.
[Trommelwirbel]
AARON: Natürlich. [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Ich komme mir schon vor wie mit dem Sturmi.
AARON: Warum? Hat er da auch überall reingeguckt?
STURMI: Sally Krug haben.
Neh! Was?!
Und wir machen deinen eigenen Tee, ne?
SALLY: Ja, jetzt machen wir hier Tee.
STURMI: Was ist das für einer?
SALLY: Das ist auch fertig.
AARON: Ja, aber das ist cool, was du alles hast.
Demnächst kommen übrigens Autos.
SALLY: Dann etwas Hartweizengries.
AARON: Was macht es?
SALLY: Das macht den Boden so crunchy.
Also ich finde es echt mega gut.
AARON: Ah, ja!
SALLY: Dann hier reinlegen.
Und jetzt öffnen wir den Teig so mit den Händen.
Bist du Randesser – ja, nein?
AARON: Ja, am liebsten, wenn da Käse drin ist.
SALLY: Oh, können wir auch machen.
AARON: Ich esse den Rand immer mit, weil…
Oh, meiner hat ein Loch.
SALLY: Ja, du musst ganz vorsichtig sein.
AARON: Was mache ich denn jetzt?
SALLY: Wieder zusammenflicken.
AARON: Wieder alles zusammenmachen?
SALLY: Nein, nein, nur das Loch zusammenflicken.
AARON: Okay.
SALLY: Magst du einen dicken Rand oder nicht so?
AARON: Nein, eher dünn.
SALLY: Dünn, okay. Ich mag eher dick. Deswegen…
[Beide lachen]
AARON: Ja, das sehe ich an Murat.
SALLY: Oh je, voll die Vorlage.
Deswegen lasse ich den Rand ein bisschen dicker,
aber du kannst den ruhig dünner machen.
Also ich ziehe den noch bisschen, damit ich ihn noch ausdünnen kann.
Man muss so richtig mit Gefühl…
AARON: Da bist du bei mir an der richtigen Stelle.
SALLY: Du hast gesagt, du kannst gut massieren. Ich dachte, du…
AARON: Nein, das habe ich abgebrochen.
Ich kann gar nicht so viele Sachen gut.
SALLY: So, dann gebe ich noch einmal Öl darunter.
AARON: Kann ich nicht hier vom Rand ein bisschen flicken?
Hier ein bisschen was, hier ein bisschen was…
SALLY: Ja, ja!
AARON: So, fertig.
SALLY: Sieht gut aus.
AARON: Nicht kaputt machen!
SALLY: Ich gucke nur, dass er nicht später klebt.
Guck mal, hier hast du noch ein Loch.
Wenn da jetzt Tomatensauce daruntergeht, dann klebt er.
AARON: Okay, Tschuldigung! Und jetzt?
SALLY: Dann Tomatensauce.
AARON: Mit dem Löffel? Einfach drauf?
SALLY: Ja. So, wie du willst – einfach belegen.
AARON: Ich bin ja einer von der Sorte, der sagt: Viel hilft viel.
[Musik]
SALLY: Der Ofen ist schon vorgeheizt auf Unterhitze oder Pizzastufe,
wenn man sie hat.
Gut, ich nehme bei mir noch Sucuk drauf. Du willst ja nicht…
AARON: Packe ich Hähnchen drauf oder macht man’s vorher noch in der…
SALLY: Ich hatte überlegt, das vorher noch kurz anzubraten,
aber wir packen es mit rein,
weil das Hähnchen ganz kleingeschnitten ist. Also es passt schon.
[Musik]
So, das war er – der Pizza-Crashkurs. Und, schwierig?
AARON: Nein, eigentlich nicht, aber wenn du mich jetzt fragst,
wie ich den Teig machen müsste – habe ich schon wieder vergessen.
SALLY: Echt jetzt?!
AARON: Du drehst zig Videos am Tag;
hast zeitgleich einen Sahnebeutel in der Hand. [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Okay, wir backen sie
und dann probierst du einmal, okay? [Aaron bejaht]
AARON: Ach hier ist der Ofen. [Sally bejaht]
[Musik]
SALLY: Kleiner Tipp: Wir haben alle Reste hier in der Pfanne…
AARON: Oooh!
SALLY: … und dann überbacken wir sie jetzt einfach im Ofen, ja?
Ihr seid zu dritt, wir haben ein Riesenteam.
Backen wir so? [Aaron und Josh stimmen zu]
AARON: Aber man muss mal sagen: Die sieht aus wie in der Pizzeria,
die sieht aus wie zu Hause.
SALLY: Ja, sieht gut aus.
Also was ich tatsächlich an Käse drüber mag, ist,
dass die Zutaten unten drunter so richtig schön garen.
Das ist wie so ein Schmortopf.
AARON: Deswegen habe ich es gemacht.
SALLY: Es ist nur optisch natürlich anders schöner,
aber ich finde es so vom Geschmack her besser.
AARON: Die inneren Werte zählen.
SALLY: Ja, die inneren Werte zählen.
AARON: Du hast es jetzt schon gebraten
und jetzt kommt es noch in den Ofen?
SALLY: Jetzt überbacken wir es noch.
Jetzt guck mal! Guck mal, wie gut sie aussieht! Boah!
AARON: Aber schneiden kann ich wirklich nicht. Ich durfte in der Kita…
Guck mal! [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Sieht gut aus. Ich finde, sie sieht gut aus.
AARON: Aber für ein Foto für den Blog würde ich deine nehmen.
SALLY: Wir nehmen beide.
AARON: Aber meine posten wir nur. Ja, die sieht schon stark aus!
SALLY: So, dann probiere mal!
AARON: Die ist noch voll heiß.
SALLY: Ja okay.
AARON: Oder?
SALLY: Komm dann überbrücken wir…
[Musik] Es gibt jetzt einen Idiotentest mit dir.
Einfache Fragen aus der Back- und Koch-Community.
Das 1x1 des Kochens und Backens, okay? [Aaron stimmt zu]
Was bedeutet emulgieren?
AARON: Bitte nochmal?
SALLY: Emulgieren.
AARON: Das ist ganz einfach: Wenn du den Zucker erhitzt.
[Biep] [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Das ist karamellisieren.
AARON: Ach so.
SALLY: Emulgieren… Emulgator: Was macht ein Emulgator?
AARON: Man, jetzt frag nicht nach.
SALLY: Ein Emulgator bindet 2 Dinge.
Chemie: Wasser und Öl vermischen sich nicht.
Da braucht man einen Emulgator dafür.
Salatdressing: Essig und Öl vermischt sich nicht.
Da brauchst du einen Emulgator.
AARON: Ei!
SALLY: Z.B. Ei.
AARON: Ja, das habe ich heute gelernt. Milch…
SALLY: Senf. [Aaron wiederholt] Sehr gut! Emulgator/emulgieren.
AARON: Der Ofen piept! Okay, eine Frage nehme ich noch.
[Sally lacht]
SALLY: Was passiert, wenn man die Sahne überschlägt?
AARON: Ist zu hart, wird zu steif.
[Biep]
SALLY: Ich habe es dir vorhin extra nicht verraten.
Was passiert, wenn du sie überschlägst?
AARON: Die wird sauer.
[Biep]
SALLY: Nein, sie wird zu Butter.
AARON: Ach so.
SALLY: Woraus besteht Marzipan?
AARON: Wer hat die Millennium Trilogie geschrieben?
[Beide lachen]
SALLY: Woraus besteht Marzipan?
AARON: Esse ich gern.
SALLY: Was ist da drin? Zwei Hauptzutaten.
AARON: Schokolade.
[Biep]
AARON: Marzi…
[Biep] [Sally lacht]
AUS DEM HINTERGRUND: Rosenwasser? [Sally stimmt zu]
SALLY: Das ist aber keine Hauptzutat.
AARON: Ja, wirklich!
SALLY: Die Hauptzutat ist…? Ach komm!
AARON: Ich weiß es nicht!
SALLY: Mandel und Zucker. Rosenwasser ist dazu da,
um alles dann noch schön zu aromatisieren und zu verbinden
AARON: Da bin ich ehrlich: Da wäre ich nie darauf gekommen.
SALLY: Was ist beim Backen die Impfmethode? [Lacht]
AARON: Dass man sie hinterher beim Backen…
Du lässt einen Hohlraum und dann, wenn es gebacken ist,
machst du über das Impfen die Schokosauce oder Sahne rein.
[Biep]
SALLY: Oh, aber Schokolade war schon gar nicht schlecht.
Impfmethode bedeutet: Schokolade bekommt beim Schmelzen,
wenn man sie falsch schmilzt, einen grauen Schleier.
Sie wird nicht fest. Impfmethode heißt,
man impft die flüssige Schokolade mit fester Schokolade.
Dann kommt sie auf die perfekte Temperatur.
AARON: Hey, das war’s auch schon wieder…
SALLY: Was muss man beim Biskuit sieben: Zucker oder Mehl?
AARON: Mehl! [Tick]
SALLY: Sehr gut!
AARON: Ich habe geraten. [Beide lachen]
Zucker oder MEEEHL!
SALLY: Das musst du wissen. Das haben wir heute gemacht.
Wie geht die berühmte Mürbeteigformel?
Wir haben heute Mürbeteig zubereitet.
AARON: Warte, was war denn da drin? Das waren…
[Grillengeräusche] 200 g Mehl, Butter irgendwie…
SALLY: Und was noch?
AARON: Hefe?
SALLY: Nein!
AARON: Was war es denn? Du hast es vorhin hier so schön…
Das, das,…
SALLY: Komm! Was war es? Komm!
Mürbeteig – es war, ich helfe dir, das 1-2-3-Prinzip.
AARON: Zucker, Salz…
SALLY: 1-2-3: Wovon war 1 Teil?
AARON: Ei…weiß? Gelb? [Sally verneint]
SALLY: 1 Teil Zucker, 2 Teile Butter, 3 Teile Mehl. 1-2-3!
Was ist Nussbutter? [Lacht]
AARON: Nussbutter ist Butter,
die man durch das Zerstampfen von Nüssen gewinnt.
[Biep]
SALLY: Nein. Das ist Butter, die man ein bisschen braunwerden lässt.
Woran erkennt man schlechte Eier? [Lacht]
AARON: Am Geruch? [Tick]
SALLY: Ja. Schätzfrage: Wie schwer ist ein Ei der Größe M ungefähr?
AARON: 45 g.
SALLY: Mit oder ohne Schale?
AARON: Mit.
[Biep]
War 45 g richtig? [Sally bejaht] Ich habe nur geraten.
Ich dachte zwischenzeitlich, ich sage 200 g, aber dann dachte ich,
das ist ein bisschen viel.
SALLY: Woraus besteht Pudding?
AARON: Kommt drauf an. Wenn es Vanillepudding ist, ist Vanille drin.
SALLY: [Stimmt zu] Und die Hauptzutaten?
AARON: Joghurt!
[Biep] [Alle lachen]
Ich habe keine Ahnung!
SALLY: Oh man! Krass, ich wollte eigentlich dieses Quiz gar nicht machen,
weil ich dachte, 1x1 des Backens und Kochens…
AARON: Ich habe mit Sally ein Quiz auf meinem Zweitkanal gedreht.
Guckt es euch an! [Tick]
SALLY: Was ist der Unterschied zwischen einem Kuchen oder einer Torte?
Wann ist es eine Torte?
AARON: [Flüstert] Ich hasse dich. [Sally lacht]
SALLY: Ich liebe dich auch.
AARON: Was haben wir denn heute gemacht? Einen Kuchen!
SALLY: Heute war es eine Tarte. Das ist wieder etwas anderes. Und Pizza.
AARON: Ein Kuchen enthält…
SALLY: Ach komm! Wann ist es ein Kuchen und wann ist es eine Torte?
AARON: Wenn viel Sahne drauf ist. Ich weiß… Ja?
Wenn viel Sahne drauf ist? [Tick]
SALLY: Dann ist es eine Torte.
AARON: Ah okay.
SALLY: Ich erlöse dich. Wir essen jetzt Pizza.
AARON: Jaaa! Egal, ob sie heiß ist oder nicht. [Sally lacht]
Mmh! Die ist super! Der Käse ist toll!
Den schmeckt man. [Beide lachen] Mmh!
SALLY: Ich finde sie auch gut. Das war ja die Sorte…
Chicken Supreme von Pizza Hut.
AARON: Ah wirklich? [Sally bejaht]
Deine schmeckt besser!
SALLY: Wir haben jetzt praktisch Pizza Hut nachgemacht.
AARON: Finde ich gut.
SALLY: Also probiert es gern aus. Ich würde sagen:
Praktikant war sehr gut. Pizzabacken 1x1 gemeistert.
AARON: Ich habe aber alles schon wieder vergessen.
Ich muss mir das Video nochmal anschauen.
SALLY: Aber dann kannst du jetzt zu Hause auch immer Pizza backen,
ganz fleißig. Mach nicht so schwer!
AARON: Kann ich noch ein Stück bei dir essen?
ELA: Mama?
SALLY: Ja na klar! Ich esse dann auch ein Stück bei dir, mit viel Käse.
AARON: Was können wir für dich tun?
SALLY: Ja, Schatz?
ELA: Können wir gleich…?
SALLY: Oh, ist das für den Aaron? Hast du es für ihn ausgedruckt?
ELA: Nein.
SALLY: Der Super-Pizzabäcker.
AARON: Sie hat nein gesagt.
ELA: Ich möchte, dass wir das auf dem…
SALLY: Also Tschüss!
AARON: Ciao!
ELA: Mama, können wir Backpapier und ein Bügeleisen nehmen?
SALLY: Ja. Willst du Bügelperlen machen?
ELA: Nein.
SALLY: Okay. Was dann?
ELA: Ich will das auf ein Shirt machen.
SALLY: Geht aber nur mit Bügelpapier.
ELA: Oh. Dann nehmen wir Bügelpapier. Ist egal. Komm mit!
[Musik]